what up we're getting a lot of questions  about the live Holiday Spectacular so  let's just clear them all up right now  what is happening we'll be in the studio  doing a virtual holiday show nothing  sexual when is happening when is  happening isn't really a sentence but uh  anyway it is happening this Monday at 9  00 PM Eastern 6 p.m Pacific nobody does  a live stream podcast for no reason not  a question but valid we're doing it for  charity all proceeds from ticket sales  will go to a worthy cause who are we  doing at verses  I mean each other you know will compete  in various challenges to determine once  and for all who is your favorite host  the person team favorite host will  donate all the proceeds to the charity  of their choice you see this way  everybody wins except for their  Charities which will lose go to  moment.co always sunny to purchase your  ticket to the party